yes the microphone is on okay officially
laughs the court no you continue reading
soon no stop telling me what to okay so
based on leave the volume this is like
that prodigy music video we saw did the
guy running around just drinking and
being a dick and penis psychopath who do
you voodoo [ __ ] start yes we are
recording Oh Jackson no but we got it
all makes oh not again let me sync the
audio okay I got him I got him no
storage device hard drivers been
selected Thank You Logan no Sam be that
guy could throw stuff go back to low no
he can hit people in the figure with the
black guy it's a foreign language he's
basically like my daddy went to prison I
was to his way dead guy is literally
just the black guy he's so my black of a
Miss aggressively black dick Craig he's
like the samuel l jackson of people
except for samuel l jackson is cool and
not a black stereotype but I mean
yeah except he is one hundred percent
the stereotype
don't question it question no cuts ah
damn it don't show my name gonna have to
censor this so much so my name doesn't
pop up hello there ah damn it hold on
turn turn up Jackson damn Fe [ __ ] engage
the second monitor huh you're fired
you're fired okay we have a special
guest star named his neza take two we
have a special guest star today his name
is TC Laxman he's a close personal
friend of ours whoa what that didn't
nothing oh yeah okay okay when I run I
could spring no I don't know no just
sprint ever wait wait wait wait along a
comfortable bed hold on one you missed
something you missed something go back
it's the opposite of progress take a
bath who needs money they're gonna
zombie wait you don't know you're in a
zombie apocalypse take the money take
the money before you realize that it's a
zombie apocalypse and that currency is
now waste lyst I mean useless [ __ ] no I
think you could go too much progress
Jackson you're going the wrong way you
missed the thing the cool thing use the
door Jackson stop dry humping the
doorknob no I know you don't I'll tell
you ought to live your life yes you do
know this is like that trailer was a lie
that trailer was such a lot okay so hey
everyone look at this dark dramatic game
about like zombie apocalypse know what
this is heavy rain all over again ah my
father
I'm a father to plank mother too i'm
alive i'm agent nom and jayden of the
FBI I'm looking for Paco I'm a father to
Paco there ain't no Paco here fella get
lost aight the blanket why are you
wearing a shirt because I'm a bad guy
alright fair enough he has a coat with
his name on it [ __ ] good lord I'm free
free college I can't you miss su thamma
be really upset we're gonna leave him
who ordered the pizza extra sausage cook
you porn music right now no I'll just
edit some in imagine what is even going
on when I start this doesn't have
anything to do with elevators
well that elevated quickly I'm sorry
it's zombie Deadpool keep creeping on me
hey that's your [ __ ] head on swami
mama hahahahaha oh [ __ ] on the body and
then you look you right in the gavel me
but you're right in the Gabba yeah you
creeping on me night once every 10 I
hope to find them rest let me play now
oh that one punch oh I need to punch
everything no i want to point everything
i'll do it good though I hooked um are
you gonna run together you did just
right on the money [ __ ] [ __ ] swear
on me mama hook your right in the gaba
zombies all over the girl all over the
gap these mangy kids cry yet I'm Vicky
yeah cutscene powers how is that guy
running that he's only his clothes Ambo
Oh zambia's apparently can write that oh
[ __ ] well even mess in the end it didn't
even matter yet it didn't even matter
this is a really sing singing video
we've been singing along no I got do
this no no no progress progress in fact
you already did you know I've been
roofied uh-uh I'm doing these zombies
are touching you inappropriately wait
not ahead no I bloody head oh you guys
can you again George bloody head I said
nod your head dananana na they're not
your head remember that will smith song
at the end of men in black too he
stopped a wonder weapon he can find a
way I need a weapon ah well the bottle
give me them give me the controller or
10 take a straight through there should
just be loud rap music playing right now
I can do anything well get in trouble
copyright don't matter it doesn't even
matter my skin doesn't even matter words
they will not cut scene I can hear me
enough this time going Shh she prolly
can't okay look that guy it looks like
the black Ebenezer Scrooge he's
basically Mike Tyson voice on the radio
tell me hey you know steve blum is every
character in this game some useless i
think it's ironic he he was like it
could be like a like a jail inmate are
you gonna do the wrong thing and not but
he's a lifeguard yeah good loving it
fast off we need an access card where he
saying people tattoos are automatically
all inmates well don't look at him he's
like them I mean he is Australian you
know what you know why they call each
other mate they all used to be inmates
together it's like Canada's like a you
are sooo piell's don't kill people
people kill people using Marcinko images
of australia on your chest yes well
that's when you go into Germany or
Austria no that's the same no sir no in
Germany and Austria you get
exponentially more attractive and also
you kind of get strange strange suddenly
you want to owe yourself up and work
out and also gets strange tiran
difficulty oh everyone ever every vile
and then and then you eventually become
governor remember when Arnold
Schwarzenegger compared working out
Terry acylating like it it's like coming
on the boat it's like coming before a
show it's like coming on the stage yes
Arnold Schwarzenegger compared working
out two ozs oh I wish we are still
playing condemned so the punching could
be good no man condemns story is really
weird and dumb but it has awesome
punching looking right leg ever haha
poke him sideways okay so this is the
first one where I say the f-word oh
there's a walker oh man never even begun
to make Walking Dead references oh but
it's coming now for all you girls bball
justify gear the videos are usually mess
but now there's a third guy so it's like
Oh three times oh wait good yes be to go
talk to him oh hey man what you doing to
a spiteful diving knife thanks man okay
so anyway this is like the only
character in the game with any depth or
any care about the whole zombie thing
everyone else is just like go get me
supplies
yes I've done it we ever send it we have
ascended to godhood nothing can stop us
now kids the pipe is a universal
constant Jackson ready haha know what
that wasn't what what my intention was
okay you got red we got no flaws because
Xavier spray no no this need all this
whole damn gut nat out door you kinetic
i command you to open the pipe has said
do as I say I will tear this whole
universe down with the pipe the pipe can
destroy all activate montage of dubstep
pipe smashing gameplay in play yeah yep
look yeah I'm gonna make this even shaky
ER and editing oh look bad no II
billions I've been told that my life
might you BAM level of ice rusted the
door so hard it just it just opened in
one one thing as a precaution
now I gotta turn that puff his copyright
laws can't do that copper pipe can't
handle this much punching look at it
it's all Benton it rattled the squad
look at this pipe man he's all mangling
the plot in the background why is this I
can't oh wait this video is even
remotely funny why is there a woman in
bikini hey guys haha you just learned
what that was today you've already used
it I'm a lifeguard now I'm quick to
learn new words and then make them
annoying hubby he's just leave just
staring at the ceiling and crying and
sobbing just looking up oh really